WE WILL SEE YOU THEN.
♪S.
>> Tucker: GOOD EVENING AND
WELCOME TO "TUCKER CARLSON
TONIGHT."
NOT WHAT THEY CALL A MACHINE
GEERL ELECTION.
NOT A CONTEST TO DETERMINE
WHICH BRANCH OF THE
ESTABLISHMENT GETS A TURN AT
THE WHEEL.
THIS ISN'T A CLINTON DOLE 96
KIND OF RACE WHERE YOU ARE
PRETTY SURE THAT NO MATTER
WHO WINS THINGS AREN'T GOING
TO CHANGE VERY MUCH.
THIS YEAR, THE ONE THING YOU
CAN BE CERTAIN OF IS THAT
THINGS CAN BE VERY DIFFERENT
WHEN IT'S OVER.
THE ISSUES AT STAKE ARE
BIGGER THAN JUST THE ECONOMY
OR EVEN OUR FOREIGN POLICY
COMMITMENT.
2020 IS ABOUT THE BROADEST
POSSIBLE QUESTION.
WHAT KIND OF COUNTRY SHOULD
WE HAVE?
WHO SHOULD LIVE HERE?
WHAT WILL AMERICA LOOK LIKE
50 YEARS FROM NOW?
THERE ARE A LOT OF POSSIBLE
ANSWERS TO THOSE QUESTIONS,
BUT LEADING DEMOCRATS APPEAR
TO HAVE SETTLED ON THEIR
POSITION.
AMERICA, THEY ARE TELLING
US, SHOULD BE A LOT MORE
LIKE CALIFORNIA.
LISTEN TO FORMER NEW YORK
MAYOR MICHAEL BLOOMBERG
EXPLAIN HIS VISION FOR THE
COUNTRY HE IS HOPING TO
LEAD.
>> I THINK THAT CALIFORNIA
CAN SERVE AS A GREAT EXAMPLE
FOR THE REST OF THIS
COUNTRY.
YOU HAVE LED THE WAY ON
CLIMATE CHANGE, ON FIGHTING
GUN VIOLENCE AND ON CRIMINAL
JUSTICE.
AND YOU HAVE AS IMPORTANTLY
WELCOMED IMMIGRANTS WITH
OPEN ARMS.
CALIFORNIA IS PART OF THIS
COUNTRY THAT IS SOMETHING
THE REST OF THE COUNTRY
LOOKS UP TO.
>> Tucker: SO MICHAEL
BLOOMBERG GRADUATED FROM
HIGH SCHOOL ALMOST 60 YEARS
AGO.
AND AT THAT TIME A LOT OF
WHAT HE JUST SAID WAS TRUE.
THE REST OF THE COUNTRY
REALLY DID LOOK UP TO
CALIFORNIA.
MILLIONS OF AMERICANS MOVED
TO CALIFORNIA IN SEARCH OF A
BETTER LIFE.
IT HAD THE NATION'S BEST
PUBLIC SCHOOLS AND WORLD
CLASS UNIVERSITIES THAT
ESSENTIAL LIVER WERE FREE.
GRADUATES FROM THOSE
UNIVERSITIES CREATED SILICON
VALLEY AMONG OTHER THINGS
THE BIRTHPLACE OF THE
DIGITAL AGE.
COMPARED TO THE REST OF
AMERICA, POVERTY IN
CALIFORNIA THEN WAS LOW AND
OPPORTUNITY WAS VIRTUALLY
UNLIMITED.
THE PEOPLE WHO MOVED HERE IN
160 WHEN BLOOMBERG GRADUATED
HIGH SCHOOL FOUND THEIR
AMERICAN DREAM.
BUT THINGS HAVE CHANGED.
NOW THE CHILDREN AND
GRANDCHILDREN OF THOSE
PEOPLE ARE FLEEING
CALIFORNIA.
WE SPENT THE LAST WEEK HERE
IN LOS ANGELES FOR THE SHOW.
IN SOME WAYS IT'S STILL A
VERY BEAUTIFUL PLACE.
THE WESTERN PARTS OF THE
CITY ARE SOME OF THE RICHEST
NEIGHBORHOODS IN THE WORLD.
YOU WOULD WANT TO LIVE
THERE.
THEY ARE IMMACULATE.
HUGE SWATHS OF MODERN LOS
ANGELES SHOCK THE CONSCIOUS
OF ANYONE WHO DRIVES BY.
FILTH AND DISORDER CLUSTERS
OF ADDICTS.
BLOCK AFTER BLOCK.
THIS IS FOOTAGE OUR PRODUCER
SHOT YESTERDAY.
IT HAS A QUARTER OF THIS
COUNTRY'S HOMELESS.
ADJUSTED FOR THE COST OF
LIVING.
CALIFORNIA HAS THE HIGHEST
POVERTY RATE OF ANY STATE IN
AMERICA.
NEARLY A QUARTER OF ITS
PEOPLE ARE POOR.
WHY?
THERE ARE A LOT OF REASONS
HERE ARE SOME.
THE STATE HAS THE MOST
EXPENSIVE HOUSING IN THE
CONTINENTAL UNITED STATES.
MOST EXPENSIVE GASOLINE
THANKS TO THE TAXES.
THE FREE WORLD CLASS
UNIVERSITIES THOSE ARE LONG
GONE.
THE UNIVERSITY OF CALIFORNIA
SYSTEM HAS SOME OF THE
HIGHEST IN STATE TUITION
RATES IN THE COUNTRY.
AS WE CHRONICLED LAST WEEK
IN OUR SERIES AMERICA
DYSTOPIA.
NO CITY MORE ACCURATELY
REPRESENTS THE IMPLOSION OF
CALIFORNIA THAN SAN
FRANCISCO.
>> GET THE [BLEEP] OUT OF
HERE.
[BLEEP], [BLEEP]
>> I HAVE BEEN HERE 42 YEARS
[BLEEP]
>> I FEAR FOR MY SAFETY.
>> YOU NEVER KNOW WHAT'S
COMING AROUND THE COUNTRY.
>> FILM ME YOU MOTHER
[BLEEP]
>> I LIVE A BLOCK AWAY.
[BLEEP] YOU.
>> THIS CITY IS MESSED UP.
IT'S VERY MESSED UP.
>> I'M NOT FORCING THEM TO
MOVE BUT I TALK TO HIM AND
ENCOURAGE HIM TO MOVE.
>> DO YOU THINK YOU WILL BE
HOMELESS THE REST OF YOUR
LIFE?
>> YEAH.
>> YOU PUSH THEM OUT AND
THEN WHAT STAYS?
>> Tucker: IT'S MESSED UP.
REALLY MESSED UP.
THAT'S RIGHT.
SO FINDING
SO FIND PG
SO FIND PEOPLE LEAVING
CALIFORNIA DECADES.
NOW THE FLOW HAS REVERSED.
EVERY YEAR THE NUMBER OF
PEOPLE LEAVING CALIFORNIA
FOR OTHER PLACES EXCEEDS THE
NUMBER OF PEOPLE MOVING IN
BY MORE THAN 100,000.
IF IT WEREN'T FOR THE
CONSTANT STREAM OF
IMMIGRANTS FROM ABROAD,
CALIFORNIA'S POPULATION
WOULD BE FALLING AND FAST.
THE MIDDLE CLASS UTOPIA OF
OLD HAS EVAPORATED.
THE STATE IS IN CRISIS.
THAT'S OBVIOUS TO EVERYONE
WHO LIVES HERE, CERTAINLY.
BUT NOT TO THE PEOPLE WHO
RUN CALIFORNIA INSTEAD OF
FIXING PROBLEMS FORCED
PEOPLE TO LEAVE SPENT YEARS
ON POLICIES FRIVOLOUS AND
COUNTER PRODUCTIVE.
BANNING PLASTIC STRAWS.
REQUIRING BACKGROUND CHECKS
TO BUY SHOTGUN SALES.
TRANSMISSION OF HIV.
HUH?
GOVERNOR GAVIN NEWSOM'S MOST
RECENT BUDGET PROPOSES
80 MILLION IN ADDITIONAL
FUNDING TO PROVIDE FREE
HEALTHCARE FOR ILLEGAL
IMMIGRANT SENIORS.
WHO WANTS THAT?
THIS IS THE STATE THAT
DEMOCRATS ARE CALLING THE
MODEL FOR AMERICA.